- Hi everyone, this is Jeremy
Schifeling at Khan Academy.
I'm joined by our amazing leader of
professional learning, Meaghan Pattani.
Meaghan has a real treat
in store for you today,
because she's gonna walk you through,
not the educator experience that
you're used to on the site,
but the student experience.
So, you can see exactly what
your students are seeing,
and deliver them an
awesome experience with all
the remote learning challenges
we all have at this moment.
So that being said,
Meaghan is gonna start to share
with you what it looks like
through the lens of a
student using Khan Academy,
and then in true webinar fashion,
if you have any questions whatsoever,
you can ask those at any time
using the questions feature,
and we'll take those both throughout,
and then also at the end.
So that being said,
thank you so much for joining us today,
and I'll turn it over to Meaghan.
- Thanks so much, Jeremy.
So, we're gonna jump right
in, and just a quick note of
what we will and will not cover today.
We're gonna cover the student experience,
and I know a lot of teachers and
parents have a lot of
questions about this.
We're gonna walk through
the student experience on
Khan Academy to help you as parents,
or teachers, better understand what
your students and or
children are learning.
But, we will not cover today
the teacher and parent experiences.
We have some of the resources
about parent teacher experience,
and if you'd like to take a look at those,
definitely reach out to
our keep learning site,
keeplearning@khanacademy.org,
and there you'll have more information
about parent and teacher experiences.
That being said, I'm gonna jump
right into our live product.
Here's how we're gonna start.
Once students login to Khan Academy,
so if they have an existing account,
either a personal account,
or one they have through
their school or district,
they log in here.
If they need to create an account,
they can do that pretty easily.
They can use that same Google login
they might have for school.
Or, if they are under 13,
you as a parent can help walk
them through that process.
Once they're logged in,
they're gonna land here.
This is what we call our learner home,
and you might be asking
yourself, well who is a learner?
We at Khan Academy view
everyone as a learner,
and especially our students.
This is where they're
gonna find everything else
they need to access on Khan Academy.
One trick we always like to
share with our students and
teachers is that anywhere you
are on the Khan Academy site,
by clicking that Khan
Academy logo at the top,
they'll return right back
to this learner home.
On this page, you'll see
a whole bunch of things.
We're gonna start at the top,
and then we'll work through the rest.
On the left hand side here,
you'll see this little avatar,
which students can update,
and you'll see their name,
and their user name, and an
option here to add their bio.
By clicking on this, students
can edit this information.
Just one thing, I always like to call out
to parents and to teachers,
is this basic information.
The user name, the avatar,
and the bio information
that students share is publicly available.
So, just to be a little bit cautious
about what they've put there.
When they land on the learner home,
they'll see if their
teacher has assigned them
course mastery or assignments.
They'll see those broken down
by class on the left hand side,
and so you can see on
my student account here,
that on my period one Algebra one class,
I have a course mastery
goal that you see here,
and then I also have
assignments from my teacher.
So, anything they'd need
from an individual class
will be there on the left hand side.
If they have courses that they'd
like to study on their own,
under this next category of information
where it says my stuff,
students will see courses.
These are courses that the student
has selected themselves to study.
When students sign up for an account,
they'll have the opportunity to pick
which courses they'd like
to study on their own.
We recommend things that they
might be studying in school,
or things that just interest them.
They can always edit those courses
by clicking the blue button at the top.
Below this, I also wanna
call out this SAT button.
For students that might
be in the high school age,
they have the opportunity to link their
college board account with
their Khan Academy account.
They can import existing
PSAT or SAT scores,
and get personalized
recommendations across math,
reading and writing, and essays.
If students want to do that,
or if they haven't taken it
yet, we also offer diagnostics.
If they add SAT, again when
they set up their account,
they have a button that offers
them to add SAT as a course.
They'll be added this SAT tab,
and they can practice
recommended exercises
fit to their personalized results.
If you scroll down a little bit further,
in the my account area, one other thing
I'd like to point out here,
is this button for teachers.
If students click on teachers,
this is where they're able to see
any teachers they're
currently connected to.
They can remove those teachers,
and if they need to join a class,
one of the easiest way for students
to join a class is to
enter the class code.
So, this is where your
students would go if
they need to input a class
code to join your class.
They would enter the class
code in the space here,
and click join the class.
Once they do that, your
name will appear in
the right hand side as a teacher.
So, if you're ever
concerned that the student
is not connected to your class properly,
have them go to this
tab, and have them check
to make sure that you are in
fact connected as a teacher.
One last thing on this
student learner home,
is this profile.
This shows students what
they've done on Khan Academy.
It shows things like how many days
have they completed work on Khan Academy.
If they've worked on any computer
programming projects, they find them here.
How many energy points have they earned,
and how many badges have they earned.
So, all of these kind
of gamification pieces
and tracking pieces can be found here.
I'm gonna go back to this course
mastery on my learner home.
This here is a course mastery goal
that's given by my teacher.
If you've assigned a course
mastery goal to your students,
this is what they see when they log in.
They'll see in this case,
that we've assigned an
Algebra one goal to this student.
It shows the course name,
when the goal is due,
and how much progress they've
made on the overall course.
By clicking on this,
it takes me directly to the course page,
so I've now gone from the learner home
to the Algebra one course.
Now, some students will navigate
to courses all on their own
by clicking this courses
button in the top left.
This shows you all the courses
that are available across Khan Academy.
However, if you've assigned
a course mastery goal,
we do recommend that students log in,
land on their learner home,
and then click on that
bar to take them directly
to the course of study
recommended for them.
From this page, you'll be
able to see all the units,
lessons,
and even a course challenge
that assesses skills
across the entire course
for this particular course.
On the left hand side,
you'll see student progress.
So, this is a overall
progress in the course,
and then each of these
bars align to a unit.
You'll see that the student
in this case has made
quite a bit of progress
in Algebra foundations.
About 93% of that unit is completed.
Whereas the one right below it,
solving equations and unique
qualities, is 64% mastered.
From here, by clicking
on a unit or a lesson,
students will jump into the lesson
or unit in which they want to work.
In this case, they'll be able to see
each of the lessons within the unit,
and the skills that are
contained within that unit.
By hovering over any of
these individual skills,
they'll see a sample of
what that skill looks like.
We know that evaluating expressions
with one variable doesn't always
make a lot of sense to students,
but if they can see a sample problem,
then they have a better understanding
of what they're asked to be working on.
Along with this, you'll see that each
of these little figures
has bars filled in.
These are indicators of the
mastery level of that skill.
The Khan Academy mastery system
has various skill levels.
For students, each skill can
be placed at a different level.
So, if they have not
attempted the skill yet,
they'll be placed at no level,
and all of the bars will be grayed out.
If they've attempted the skill,
but they've earned less than 70%
while practicing that skill,
they'll be marked as attempted.
But again, none of the bars are filled in.
If they earn more than 70%
correct from practicing
a skill in isolation on an exercise,
or correctly answer a question related
to that skill on a quiz or a test,
they'll get moved up to familiar.
If they get 100% of the
questions correct from practicing
the skill in isolation on an exercise,
they'll be moved up to familiar,
and you'll see two of these bars filled.
In order to get to mastered,
they need to show that they are competent
in that skill in two different scenarios.
They either need to complete
the exercise and get 100%,
and then demonstrate understanding
of that skill in a test
or a course challenge,
so that it shows that they are proficient
in that skill in both
isolation and in mixed review.
Or, they have to answer that
question correctly twice
on two separate unit tests,
or twice on the course challenge.
And, if students are confused at any time,
just like I just did, they can
click on this question mark,
and look at skill summary,
and this appears in every
unit on Khan Academy,
to understand how they need to,
what they need to do in order
to move up or down levels.
Now, on this unit page, you
can see each of these lessons.
In general, you'll see that on
the left hand side are opportunities
for students to learn
or acquire new skills,
where on the right hand side,
are practice opportunities for students
to demonstrate their
understanding of that skill.
So, on the left hand side,
students will find videos
and articles related
to the skill they're asked
to practice on the right.
As you move down this unit
page, you'll see a quiz.
A quiz assesses all the skills
in the preceding lesson,
and at the bottom of the
unit, you'll see a unit test,
which assesses all the
skills across the unit.
As you can see, in this unit,
I completed much of the content.
But you'll see that here,
where it says recommended,
based on quiz two, I have a little star,
and this is recommending
that I review this concept,
and then try this skill again.
Students will receive
individualized recommendation
as they make progress through the content.
While all of your
students, or your children,
may be working on the
course independently,
as they make progress on certain skills,
while maybe attempting
and struggling on others,
the program will recommend
to them specific activities
in which to engage to make more progress.
All right, so let's take a look here.
If I were to jump into
one of these exercise.
If I were to look at
this particular exercise
on evaluating expressions
with one variable,
I'll open up into this exercise window
that says ready to practice.
In this case I see seven questions,
and it should take me
about seven to 11 minutes.
Then I click let's go.
I will now receive seven questions
that are all on this same topic.
Once the student inputs an answer,
you'll see that they
get immediate feedback.
In this case, where I've
input the incorrect answer,
and it encourages me to try again,
get help, or skip for now.
This gives me an opportunity
to show you two ways students
can get help while they're
working independently.
Beneath every question, is a
question here that says stuck.
In this case, by clicking on the blue link
that says watch a video or get a hint,
the student receives videos
that are specifically related
to the skill they are attempting.
Or, if they're really stuck,
they click get a hint,
and it will walk them through this
particular problem step by step,
with the final hint being
the correct answer to the question.
One thing to note is that if
students watch the videos,
and then come back and
attempt the question,
they can still receive full credit.
If they use the hint, the
question will get marked incorrect
because the final step in the hint
is the actual answer to the question.
Again, here I go with
some instant feedback
to keep up my persistence.
If I go back to the main
page for this course,
you'll see at the top here I have
a banner that says mastery challenge.
Along with the regular
assessments built into the course,
every student will receive
mastery challenges after
they've become familiar
in at least three skills.
This mastery challenge
will highlight three skills
the student has already practiced.
These are skills specific to
that student's performance,
and when they do this,
they're able to level up,
or move to mastered in that
skill if they are successful.
What's important about this
is that mastery challenges are
personalized space repetition of skill.
We know that spiraling skills helps
to produce learning loss, and
improve knowledge retention.
We strongly encourage students to engage
in mastery challenges once
they become available.
Mastery challenges will refresh
for students every 12 hours.
Now I'm gonna jump back to
our learner home for a minute,
and so this is great if I'm
working on course mastery,
but we know many students are
using assignments as well.
Again, for that same class,
below course mastery I see assignments.
By clicking on assignments, I can see all
the current assignments
my teacher has given me.
In this case, I have a couple of videos,
indicated by these triangles,
and a couple of exercises.
For each assignment, I can see the name,
the class for which it's due,
the due date and time,
and the current status.
If I haven't attempted this activity yet,
it'll appear as a start button.
If I have, it'll show me
this current best score.
In this case, because
I haven't reached 100%,
it's encouraging me to try again.
If the assignment is
a video or an article,
instead of showing me
the try again button,
it'll show me either
completed or incompleted.
So, if I haven't started yet,
I could click start and watch this video,
and once I've finished it,
it'll show as completed.
Now, these are all my current assignments.
They're ordered for students
with the most proximal
or soonest due date.
In this case, you can see this
assignment is due on Monday,
whereas this isn't due until Wednesday.
Students know by clicking
at the thing at the top,
that they're doing the
assignment that is due next.
If they ever wanna go back
to look at past assignments,
they can click the tab
for past on the top,
and see all of their past assignments.
Again, here you'll see completed videos,
exercises, and in this case,
something I haven't
completed that is now late.
If I go back to active,
these are my current assignments
again, and here's the name.
By clicking on the name of the assignment,
or the start button,
I'm taken directly to that activity.
So, instead of having to navigate
through the entire course,
it takes me directly to the assignment
that my teacher has given me,
and jumps into that exercise.
Just like with course mastery,
it's the same exercises.
I'll jump into the activity,
and receive the same
personalized support and instant feedback.
Last thing I wanna go over before
we open this up to questions,
is that from this student,
this learner home,
on the left hand side, under my account,
is a tab for progress, and
this is very similar to
what parents and teachers can see.
By clicking on progress, I can
see my progress as a student,
and I can alter the time window,
what type of content I'm looking at,
and which type of activities.
From here, I can see my time spent,
and it's broken into two sections here.
My 14 minutes indicate the amount
of time I've spent on exercises.
This is the amount of time students
have spent actively
engaged with questions.
45 minutes of total
learning time, which means,
this is the total amount of time
I've spent learning on Khan Academy.
This doesn't include things
like time students spend
changing their avatars,
or navigating around site.
This is time they spent engaged
with any sort of assessment, exercise,
videos, articles, anything
that is active learning.
Then below this, each of
the activities the student
has engaged with, it shows
me what the activity was,
when did I engage with it,
my current mastery level,
whether that was up or down
in terms of mastery level.
The total number of questions
I answered correctly
out of the total number of problems
in that exercise or quiz,
and then the time spent on
that particular activity.
In some cases, you'll
even see a little bar
that says multiple skill changes.
In that case, it means that
multiple skills were assessed,
and the student had changes
in levels across multiple skills.
In that situation, by
students clicking on that,
they'll be able to see the
same type of levels and changes
across all the skills that
they used in that exercise.
Now, we've gone through
a lot fairly quickly.
When in doubt, if anything
seems unfamiliar to students,
or they're ever concerned,
they can always go to the help center.
Here, by clicking on
the navigation button,
again, students can jump
back to their learner home,
alter their settings, or
in this case, get help.
So, the last thing we
wanna call out is that
if students are ever in need of help,
by clicking on their own
name and selecting help,
they'll be directly taken to
the Khan Academy help center.
Here, they can look at
frequently asked questions,
or report a problem, so
if they're having trouble
with their account or finding things,
they can always receive help
from our help center here.
Now, I'm gonna stop here, and
we're gonna open it up to,
we're gonna open it back up to questions.
- All right, so first of all
Meaghan, thank you so much.
This is an awesome tour de
force of a student experience,
so thanks for laying it out so clearly.
We've got a ton of questions.
I'm gonna try to sort of go to
the ones that I'm seeing
over and over again.
- Sure.
- To really make sure that we hit home.
This is a questions from Yanna,
but it's certainly asked by
a number of teachers as well.
Which is, Khan has so much rich content,
but a lot of it is in the text format.
That can be tough for students
who are struggling with reading ability.
Is there any way for
students to engage with this
and have those questions read aloud,
as opposed to be forced
to read them themselves?
- Yeah, I think that's a
question we do receive a lot,
especially from our teachers
of younger students,
or teachers who teach
English language learners.
We do not offer an in-product
text to speech option,
and I know we hear a lot of that.
A couple of recommendations though,
for those students that
may be having trouble,
that may have additional
needs and things like that,
we are enabled for screen readers.
If the case is for students
with particular need
that have learning challenges,
where they might need that screen reader,
we are adapted for that.
I will highlight for our younger learners,
our Khan Academy Kids app,
which is designed for
learners two through seven,
recently released a teacher tool set
where teachers can assign things,
and that does have a
text to speech option.
If you have younger learners,
that release on the teacher
tools just came this week.
It's super exciting, so if
you have younger learners,
I highly encourage you
to take a look at that.
But, we do hear that,
and it's great feedback
that we love to have.
- Cool, and that's perfect,
because we had a number
of early elementary
and preschool teachers
who were saying hey,
Khan Kids seems great,
but it's not really teacher
friendly, and now it is.
This is brand new information.
We just linked to it in the chat section.
- Yeah, brand new, the
features just became live
in the app store in the last 48 hours.
Teachers can now go
into Khan Academy Kids,
it's really exciting,
and they can see what students are doing.
They can connect what they're
doing at home and in school,
and make assignments within the app.
Definitely check that out,
and please give us feedback,
because we're learning
and growing on that.
- Oh, and even if you have your own kids
running around at home in that age range,
feel free to use those
teacher tools to make sure
that they're getting
assigned the right content.
- Yes, absolutely.
- Meaghan and I are
both in that same boat,
so we're definitely thinking it.
(laughing)
Question from Jan.
This is the question I've
been getting not just
in the webinar, but in my email
for the last several weeks.
My students are saying hey,
I've been watching these videos,
but then the teacher's not
seeing them getting checked off
in that teacher dashboard on the backend.
What could be causing
that disconnect between
what the student says is happening,
and what the teacher is seeing?
- Couple of things.
So, number one, students
only get credit for watching
a video if they watched
at least 90% of the video,
and they watch it no faster
than two times regular speed.
So, if students are
putting it on fast forward,
or you know, if students are
only watching half the video,
they're not gonna get credit for that.
They have to actually watch the video.
The other thing is, if students just put
the video on and forget about it,
Khan Academy won't give
them credit if it times out.
So, if they just left it
on and forgot about it,
or left it on and then went
to do something in the other room,
which not that our students
would ever do that,
but we do see that happen.
So, they have to make sure
that they are engaged with
that and not just ignoring it.
That's one set of things that can happen.
The other case that we
strongly encourage is that,
a lot of students have both a
personal and a school account,
and it is most likely the school account
is the one attached to the teacher.
I would go back and verify
with your student that they are
logged in to the account
that's attached to your class.
They can check on that
learner home whether or not
it's their personal or if
it's their school account.
Just by looking at the left hand column
and seeing if their classes are there,
or checking that teacher's tab.
I would double check that they
are logged in to the class,
and I would double check
that they are watching
the video actively in its entirety.
- Oh, great advice.
And then, going back
to the very beginning,
and this is the last
question we have time for.
- Sure.
- You know, we've been talking a lot
in the last several weeks about,
how do you motivate and engage students?
It's hard enough even when
they're in your classroom,
and now when you're
teaching them from afar,
it's even more difficult.
Casey and Brie asked respectively,
what were those energy
points that you referenced at
the beginning, and how
do students earn badges?
- You bet, really great question.
Khan Academy has some really great
gamification features built into it.
When students engage with any activity,
even if they're getting
questions incorrect,
they earn energy points,
because we really want
to recognize that effort
and that persistence.
The more successful, more
repetitive they become
in those good behaviors, the
more energy points they earn.
Those energy points allow
them to do things like upgrade
that avatar that we saw on the
top left of the learner home.
The badges come from, you
know, certain behaviors earning
certain amounts of energy points,
answering 10 or 15 questions on
the same topic correctly in a row,
or watching 15 minutes of
video on a singular topic,
showing that they're really
trying to understand concepts.
Or, completing challenges,
so if they complete
certain challenges within the product.
Those badges and energy
points are deeply connected
and are meant to engage
and gamify a little bit
to keep students motivated
while they're learning.
- Very cool, and then finally,
I know we have to go in a second,
but for those who wanna have
their questions answered
even beyond the context of this webinar,
what other resources are out there
so they can get the support
they need when they need it?
- A couple of things to recommend.
From a teacher perspective,
we have a great set
of teacher resources right
on our Khan Academy site.
When you log in as a teacher,
you'll see three tabs on the top,
and one of them is resources,
so check that out for sure.
We have a keep learning microsite,
specifically designed to support
remote teaching and learning right now.
I would check that out.
There's all sorts of
great stuff for students,
for parents, for teachers.
Everything from daily
schedules to motivation tips.
I would start with those two,
and then if you have other
questions or concerns,
definitely contact our help center.
They are really incredible,
and even during this really
high demand time for Khan Academy,
they're usually good about getting back
to you all in a matter of hours,
because it's really important
that we know that our users,
especially in a time of high need,
we're here for you and whatever
questions you might have.
- Cool, well I've included those links,
so everyone can feel
free to click into those.
That being said, you will get
a recording of this webinar.
So, if you wanna go back and look at
any particular part of
what Meaghan shared,
you can do that at your own pace.
You can also shared that
with fellow educators
and even parents, if you
wanna help them sort of
get up to speed with this experience.
Anything else you'd
recommend there Meaghan?
- One other thing.
I went through this I know
pretty quickly in a live demo,
so I've included a handout
with this webinar as well,
which is just a set of
slides that walk through
the screens we went through
today with a little bit of text.
If you'd like a little bit more time
to digest everything we went through,
that's available for you there as well.
- Cool, well on behalf of Meaghan
and the whole Khan Academy team,
we wanna thank you all for making time out
of your busy afternoon to join us.
We wish you well in this
really difficult endeavor
that we're all tackling right now.
Any final words of wisdom, Meaghan?
- Just remember that anything you're doing
right now is really incredible,
and that we are all doing the best we can,
and we are here to support
you, and stay safe.
- We wish you tremendous success.
Bye, all.